el día de hoy no conozco otro ejemplo en
Europa donde todo un servicio de policía
salva a toda una comunidad judía de la
ciudad
la idea de un servicio que ejecuta un
acto de resistencia colectiva en una
comisaría para decir no a lo que ocurre
es algo que no sabía antes de llegar a
nozi
donde decidieron todos juntos de como un
acuerdo avisarles a todas esas personas
para que pudiesen escaparse y escapar de
la muerte
el fracaso de esta real es considerado
como una excepción a Escala Nacional ya
que 30 personas ayudaron a 385 judíos
extranjeros es algo nunca antes visto
en la redada de Nancy yo tenía diez años
[Música]
Fue en 1942 tuve la suerte de
encontrarme con un equipo de policías
que me evitaron primero la redada debel
de Egipto
el señor Eduardo vino a buscarnos a
París nos trajo a Nancy y Nancy fuimos a
escondidos por el señor en su casa
dijo que Paulette es el nombre de mi
madre y el niño vienen a mi casa el día
de la redada de Nancy
es decir que el día anterior vino a
buscarnos y estábamos en su casa
entonces creo que desde el punto de
vista escondite no es posible algo mejor
que estar donde los policías
el 18 de Julio de 1942 Edward viñedo
jefe del servicio de los extranjeros
recibe de sus jefes una lista que fue
realizada por los alemanes con más de
300 apellidos
debe construir un equipo de Guardianes
de la paz querían al día siguiente el 19
a las casas todas las calles del barrio
central de Nancy donde vivían muchos
judíos extranjeros irían a detenerlos
estos policías son siete de este
servicio bajo la dirección de Edward
Piñón
que deciden decir no es en ese momento
el 18 de julio
que se juega el acto decisivo que hace
fracasar la redada
[Música]
sobre el hecho de que mi padre haya
hecho eso no sabía
Esta es una foto donde está el señor
pino
que es uno de los siete policías
mi madre y mi padre Charles tobón
policía con el señor pino
[Música]
yo nunca escuché a mi padre glorificarse
por sus actividades pasadas de servicio
y tal vez tuve conocimiento de ello en
1990 Solamente
porque nadie hablaba de ellos no pagué
mi madre siempre apoyó a mi padre
y en el momento de la guerra estuvo de
inmediato de acuerdo con él para que
participe en dichos eventos si deben no
malgre a pesar de la presencia de los
niños y el riesgo que le hacía correr a
la familia
Me digo que mi padre tuvo que tener
coraje pero mi madre también
[Música]
tomar un riesgo es importantes lo
hicieron concertando con sus esposas
es decir que esos policías les avisan a
sus propias familias que harían un acto
de resistencia
que probablemente sería conocido Porque
la idea es hacer fracasar una redada
deciden bajo el impulso del señor
Eduardo quien permanece en la comisaría
para no llamar la atención enviar a
todos los miembros de ese servicio para
avisarles a una mayoría de familias
entonces golpean todas las puertas y por
lo menos 250 personas fueron salvadas
ese día y es algo que el ocupante nazi
no podía desconocer
lo que es interesante y al mismo tiempo
interroga es que estos policías después
no fueron inquietados Porque creo que el
acto colectivo era inédito
y tal vez no había que hacer publicidad
alrededor de ello en la en que fue
evidente que hicieron fracasar estas
redadas
[Música]
lo que me emociona personalmente en la
historia de estos policías es el hecho
de que sean y para siempre un modelo
para todos los policías y no solo para
los policías de
policía
es de verdad
un acto de valentía
y nosotros tuvimos la suerte de
encontrarnos con gente fuera de lo común
[Música]